olá a todos
o primeiro lugar sejam todos bem vindos
ao que provavelmente para muitos aqui é
quase que um tapa na cara sobre muita
coisa que acreditava tá certo e tá vendo
que nossa tem um mundo novo surgindo aí
e talvez do mundo de verdade ele não
seja pequeno
aliás não é e nem seja a vida é um fato
consumado e o o que as pessoas que sobem
aqui vêm falar geralmente têm por trás
sempre um grande conceito que a vontade
que cada um de nós tem e carrega de
mudar o mundo
no meu caso é a vontade de mudar o mundo
é uma coisa quase que natural
desde que eu me conheço por gente eu
sabia que tinha alguma coisa errada eu
ficava quieta
eu comecei a pensar enfim uma coisa que
eu sabia conclusão mas não sabia muito
bem a explicação lógica
eu comecei a pensar na minha infância na
minha família na minha família de sangue
na minha família de consideração
eu comecei a achar alguns fatos bem
interessantes da história começa lá
atrás na espanha de onde vêm os avós e
eles vieram a meio que fugindo da guerra
civil espanhola que o brasil
primeiro veio novo conselho brasília
depois várias outras coisas aqui em são
paulo conseguiu juntar dinheiro em deu
esse dinheiro para alguém de confiança
dele que foi de barco para espanha pegou
esse dinheiro deu para minha avó minha
avó conseguiu vir com a minha mãe aqui
para o brasil
elas chegaram aqui em 1960 anos 60 anos
70 coçava né quem fugiu da guerra civil
espanhola chega aqui em época de
ditadura não dá pra ficar quieto
então meu pai minha mãe meu tio de
consideração hélio francisco
minha tia de consideração desse rico
todos eles estavam fazendo
eles estavam indo pras ruas e minha mãe
colocando o rn é dela a prova o meu pai
colocando a liberdade dele a prova em
cada um que podia pra quê para tentar
trazer a causa justa que eles
acreditavam na época deles que eram há
há há
a guerra ea batalha dele pra mudar o
mundo que era trazer de volta à
democracia nesse país
bom tempo passou 84 surgir e aí desde
que eu me lembro quem alguma coisinha lá
coçando no meio do plano cruzado de uma
doença super séria enfim eu quase morri
e meus pais são duas opções ou eles me
colocavam lá na faca e assumem todo o
risco porque podia morrer na mesa ou
eles precisavam caçá 20 ampolas de uma
injeção no meio do plano cruzado
aqui no brasil nem todos vocês devem
lembrar mas era coisa assim de ficar
catando agulha em vários parceiros então
até hoje eu não sei como minha mãe
conseguiu mas eu tô aqui então deu certo
né
de toda forma também comunidade
espanhola e também pois no colégio
espanhol e eu vivia chegando atrasada e
já era bolsista chegava atrasada imagina
quanto que me amavam naquele colégio não
é porque eu chegava atrasado colégio
fica no morumbi o time passa na frente
do do palácio do governador o assim acho
que no mínimo uma vez por semana tinha
greve de professora tinha greve de
alguma coisa nova mãe que tá acontecendo
isso minha mãe tentava explicar eu tinha
quatro anos e eu lembro disso é óbvio o
que dava pra explicar para uma criança
de quatro anos mas enfim coçava 89 lula
versus collor coçava o impeachment do
collor coçava e aí eu comecei a ter um
pouquinho mais de consciência do do
papel dos políticos etc
eu estava naquela fazendinha tinha a
musiquinha do rio tietê era ondas
a salvar o rio tietê e aí se eleger o
governador que prometeu que ia ser
poluído rio tietê de 12 anos ele não fez
nada eu cheguei na frente da minha mãe
com oito anos a escova assim como o que
esse cara chegou na tv na frente de todo
mundo falou ele prometeu que despoluir o
rio tietê como que ele tenha coragem de
mentir e aí com 18 anos eu já sabia que
as pessoas morriam porque as pessoas
corrompem que as pessoas mentem porque
as pessoas formam é obvio que coça
tem alguma coisa errada é uma coisa
muito errada
depois disso e aí fui ficando um pouco
mais velha de 96 eu fui lá própria
espanha
todo mundo aguarda essa pc tá aqui
porque isso aqui não vai mais existir
minha filha daqui a relíquia assim
parecia que ele estava se despedindo de
um doente terminal quase um amor assim a
moeda local deles
enfim 2001 por aí eu encontrei a família
inteira já com o euro e aí eu preciso
olhar para igual
para então dá para os países todos
usarem a mesma moeda e 6 vão se matar
por conta disso
assim países têm rixa ainda parece que
dava legal pouquinho mais para frente
comecei a trabalhar e quando eu comecei
a trabalhar como vai fazer para imposto
e na hora que você vê o quanto sai de
imposto no mês e no ano o tempo que leva
para casa a restituição de imposto de
renda e tudo está sendo feito com o seu
dinheiro e se olha assim falar não para
aí eu pago tudo isso aqui e não fazem
nada apaga tudo isso aqui pra ter tantos
assessores tanto de verba de gabinete
mensalão lava-jato não não não para meu
trabalho acima de tudo resolver problema
eu passo todo dia às vezes 14 16 20
horas por dia resolvendo o problema dos
outros
é possível que tenha um problema seja
insolúvel não dá pra acreditar nisso
e aí
eu comecei a procurar alguns dados para
ter uma ideia se as pessoas já tinham se
preocupado em mensurar o tamanho desse
problema todo é descobrir que esse ano o
fmi fez isso e ele trouxe pra gente
seguinte 7 trilhões de reais são gastos
por ano com corrupção no mundo
sete tri sabe qual foi o pib do brasil
no passado 5.9 se a corrupção fosse um
país a corrupção seria a sétima economia
do mundo
aí não aí eu parei e falei 'não não não'
talvez o jeito de acabar com o dinheiro
a gente voltar piscando ou não daria pra
caramba ou não daria para proibir a
gente precisa dinheiro é começar a
pensar falar e não a gente precisa de
dinheiro porque assim ainda mais um
mundo globalizado com tecnologia com
internet mas a gente precisa repensar a
forma como a gente troca de bens e
serviços por dinheiro e como agente
processa todas as suas transações de
bens e serviços e todas essas trocas no
geral porque primeiro da maneira atual é
muito eficiente o que necessariamente
causa custo pra todo mundo e segundo
porque os sistemas que existe atualmente
eles não se conversa não tem forma
definida não tem conceito não tem nada
de bom
então tá e aí que a gente faz
como é que a gente vai mudar o mundo
como é que a gente vai resolver salvador
cheguei à seguinte conclusão o dinheiro
na hora que ele foi pensado ele ele
surgiu na verdade para facilitar essa
troca de essa transferência de utilidade
de um pra outro conforme mundo foi
crescendo e isso se provou realmente
necessário
só que ele partiu de dois pressupostos o
primeiro que só existiria um dinheiro e
logo um sistema monetário e segundo que
as pessoas em si ela tinha um negócio
chamado williams
elas tinham reputação então na hora que
eu não vender um serviço pra alguém que
eu vou vender meu cabelo
rio pra alguém a outra pessoa se ela não
me conhece ela sabe de alguém que me
conhece o que me indicou
ela não helena realmente ela ela queria
que o cabrito pode contar como é que
pode comprar dela no rosto de ninguém
isso lá atrás um tempo e vamos acelerar
o que aconteceu várias moedas para os
países e tanta tanta tanta tanta tanta
gente que que o sistema de rede de
reputação a gente tem hoje para
conseguir garante isso e mais pela
quantidade de sistemas que existem
diferentes em vários países e que não se
comunicam de maneira nenhuma a opinião
que um banco vai ter sobre mim nos
estados unidos pode ser absolutamente
diferente do que ele tem aqui e com base
em informações totalmente diferentes o
que é péssimo pra mim se eu precisar de
crédito por exemplo e péssimo pra eles
se eles precisarem controlar da onde vem
o meu dinheiro eu realmente trabalhei
por aquilo ou se eu roubei ou se eu
pratique alguma atividade ilegal
e aí como é que a gente resolve tudo que
se apresenta hoje como crypton moeda a
dor que ela está tentando resolver é
isso é colocar todas as trocas que
existem no mundo ea primeira troca que a
gente pensa sempre a monetária mas
colocar todas elas em uma base única pra
que a gente acabar com essa diferença de
informações que cada um dos players do
mundo têm sobre a mesma pessoa que se
chama assimetria de informação se a
partir do momento que você consegue
trazer todo mundo para a mesma base que
consegue reduzir se drasticamente o que
tende a retornar em benefício para todos
nós mas o que é importante a gente saber
dentro do sistema de criptografia e se o
o o que vai fazer com que a gente
repense um sistema monetário único em um
sistema monetário potencialmente global
exatamente o fato de que hoje essas
coisas todas só existem porque as
pessoas
o dem e elas podem porque primeiro elas
têm a vontade e isso na verdade a gente
nunca vai conseguir tirar mas elas têm a
capacidade de roubar de como um pedinte
fazer um monte de coisa errada e elas
têm a oportunidade porque esse monte de
assimetria de informação para quem é do
mal é quase como largar um bom dinheiro
em cima da mesa sem dono
foi no bolso vai embora como que a gente
pode fazer isso quando a gente pode
fazer essa revolução acre tocantins elas
trazem uma ideia muito bacana porque
elas não mexe na na parte da vontade
porque não teria como e elas não exigem
um consenso também de vários povos mas
elas mexem muito na capacidade que as
pessoas têm e elas mexem muito na
oportunidade por vários motivos mas um
deles o incentivo dentro do protocolo do
bloco da do big blog em todas as
operações que já aconteceram e que
aconteceram algum dia são 100%
rastreáveis tanto a origem quanto o
destino a partir do momento que você tem
isso como uma informação pública e que
você tem a rastreabilidade
talvez isso pra quem cometa atos
ilícitos já seja por si só o o um
incentivo suficiente ele não querer
fazer o segundo
exige se a tal da chave privada que a
água como se fosse a sua senha pra eu
quero transferir isso tá pra falar eu
quero fazer tal coisa eu quero registrar
isso então atua a tua vontade ela é
colocada lá de alguma maneira
a questão toda das transferências de
trocas então dentro do mundo do tamanho
e da rapidez que a gente começou a
vivenciar depois da internet
ele exige da gente repensar o sistema
monetário global ou criar no caso porque
ele não resistiu
na verdade
é quando a gente fala em troca mas só de
pensar em dinheiro mas a gente está
falando de qualquer troca quando eu
assino um contrato e depois eu preciso
pagar isso é uma troca de bem por
dinheiro ea execução desse contrato que
você dá o dinheiro recebido uma coisa é
uma troca
e na verdade assim tem um caso muito
legal que eu vivi
faz uns dois anos um casal de velhinhos
ingleses que morava em são paulo estava
vendendo em uma casinha que eles moravam
por um francês que também estava aqui
tava querendo ficar aqui em são paulo
ele estava voltando para lá o francês
tinha conta bancária lá fora eles
falaram poxa então paga a gente já lá
fora netão união européia
nossa ótimo lindo maravilhoso só tem um
problema
levava duas semanas para processar a
transação da frança na inglaterra então
que é que os vendedores acharam a gente
vai receber o dinheiro aí a gente vai no
cartório e passar a escritura pra você
do que comprador achou não a gente vai
no cartório pegou escrito depois de
transferir o dinheiro e aí quem que
salta primeiro para esse tipo de
problema que é supercomum e é comum que
a gente tenha a questão dos smart
contradisse aí você tem outras crypton
moedas que surgem exatamente para
facilitar isso e terry um é um bom
exemplo disso
a questão de transferência internacional
cara ela só existe porque hoje a forma
como a processada como são processadas
as transferências internacionais exige
uma série de intermediários no meio do
caminho dentro de uma tecnologia que é
praticamente um código morse ao sistema
de mensageria é sério
é óbvio que é ineficiente precisa de
áreas inteiras processando quase que
manualmente transações internacionais no
com que a gente pode conceber o mundo
com tudo isso de informação e com esses
sistemas correndo
na verdade a se repensar esses temas
todos e repensar os incentivos que a
gente dá
repensar a forma como a gente processo
essas transações
o que a gente quer coíbe talvez sim
causa da revolução que a gente tanto
espera e diminuir ou acabar com a dor de
é que é ter um país com a sétima
economia mundial chamado corrupção e aí
sim talvez a gente esteja falando do fim
do mundo como a gente conhece hoje mas a
criação do mundo muito melhor
obrigado
[Aplausos]